c'est l'heure de notre nouveau
rendez-vous un reportage long format
nous l'avons intitulée un jour avec à
tous les vendredis soirs nous nous
arrêterons le temps d'une rencontre une
rencontre à saisissante cette semaine
avec un homme qui n'a plus rien un sdf
comme on dit vous allez le voir vous
allez voir comment il vit et surtout où
il a trouvé refuge pour ce document
c'est à sainte marie que l'on vous
retrouve jean marc collienne avec
laurent figon au bord de la voie rapide
oui kristen nous sommes ici au bord de
la quatre voies à sainte marie vous êtes
des milliers à passer ici tous les jours
mais la plupart d'entre vous n'ont sans
doute jamais réalisé qu'un homme vit ici
sous le pont du verger c'est vrai que ça
peu un cliché quand on parle des sdf qui
vivent sous les ponts de paris et bien
ça existe aussi à la réunion jean
philippe vit sous ce pont depuis des
mois on va aller à sa rencontre
il est huit heures du matin et malgré le
vacarme de la circulation jean-philippe
dort encore
diabétique jean philippe a dû être
amputé du pied droit il a 48 ans
[Musique]
obama
yogane correa
j'aime où nous allons
azo lisent ça cache à peine le bruit des
portes et autres personnes
en temps il ya un gros bruit même
commune
jean philippe a été expulsé du logement
social qu'il occupait dans le quartier
du moufia à saint-denis depuis huit mois
il vit sous ce pont
[Musique]
allez met un coup de pub pour commencer
la journée
un café au feu de bois depuis combien de
temps il est là où
puis mois décembre l'année dernière nous
c'est devenu une maison ça n'ont pas
cette chance à réprimer point personne
pourra base à moins que ça nous sommes
couverts et de la sous le pont la
principale occupation de jean-philippe
c6 appli temps écouter la radio
il compte y radio
et évidemment à la radio il écoute
écoute madame autorités la semaine
d'information aux idiots comme maladie
et ouais madame mode vidéo
c'est pas ce travail n'était pas élu ce
travail c'est pour demain
moon qu'on peut savoir
jean-philippe se prépare à présent pour
aller en plus il enfile sur son pied
amputé une chaussette et une chaussure
pour pouvoir pédaler et c'est en vélo
qu'il rejoint le centre de st 2 oui
en tissu
oui oui
goûter tout misé avant goût d'un
rendre à la tomate i way bien tout
louati wadia couteau touati ouaga à la
maison de la fraternité dans la ruelle
turpin des repas sont servis tous les
midis sur place ou à emporter
[Musique]
la confrérie
jean-philippe traverse rapidement la
salle du restaurant
il ne s'attarde pas trop
on n'a pas envie discuter un peu avec
mes camarades ici à cause des êtres
toutes les montées tchadienne a
fairytale
[Musique]
pour lui tout seul ne souffre pas de sa
la solitude non
4 l'umir jean-philippe emmène son repas
ils préfèrent manger seuls quelque part
sur le front de mer de saint denis
à reims et troyes
un poil
dimanche d'où les femmes aiment ou
n'aiment pas des moindres le monde
pas bon
mustapha allaoui
domoni est pas une bonne passe
il faut lé moi c'était mais qui pourrait
handicaper où est mon credo la new moon
y est donc un axe allant volume des
aides il ya quelques jours nous avions
laissé jean philippe ou sur le front de
mer de saint denis on devait se
retrouver l'après midi sous le pont
louis où il vit nous l'avons entendu
jusqu'au soir il n'est jamais arrivé il
nous expliquer qu'il avait crevé un pneu
à son vélo on le retrouve donc en cette
fin d'après midi sous son pont il est en
train de préparer son dîner concernant
la marmite ça fait le oui oui avec saadi
notez qu'à préparer la salade sony
ericsson
on voit ici
nous demandons alors à jean-philippe de
venir s'asseoir un instant dans le
soleil couchant pour nous expliquer sa
vie comment il en est arrivé là
fo a milité un côté marmaille comme ça
que tu veux faire comme métier radios
basques et moi seule école bonheur que
l'ase
et comment oublier à jamais gagné un
vrai travail ici à y est retournée
bouffonnades diplôme tout où il a eu à
madame des enfants non ça ils pas pour
rien
mais madame li wei et vous saint gobain
à balma dame a fini malin combien coûte
un peu d'argent
1 la seconde main qui reçoit yake 440
guèye par rothen qui met en haut d'un
immeuble pour payer le loyer de l'eau va
se manger avec 400 euros on sait jamais
des fois où les tristes ou les
malheureux non d'un navire comme d'hab
avisé ou prix bon dieu par coup pouce à
bondir et fait rire c'est la vie comme
ça n'a rien à faire et josette père est
pareil
c'est connaît pas il est où la dent
il venait
[Musique]
au filet où la dent
mangez vous lever